so hi everyone my name is Nicole I'm
here with Elaine and both of us are part
of the society women engineers so we
both just want to give you a little bit
of background on ourselves and then talk
about some of the opportunities that
sweet has so I actually didn't know
anything about sweet when I was in high
school either I learned about it during
my senior year so sweet has a
scholarship or multiple scholarships we
give away thousands and thousands of
dollars to support girls who are excited
about stem and about engineering and
getting involved in those fields so when
I had no idea what I wanted to do i
really liked doing the engineering side
of things so I'd worked in a lab for a
couple summers at UCLA I'm in a
bioengineering lab but I also really
like the business side so I was part of
a floral arrangement business actually
that was run by my school and so we did
everything from marketing to sales to
actually like putting flower
arrangements together that was really
cool I went to Penn for college and
what's really neat is they have a
program called the management and
technology program and so you get a
degree from their business school and a
degree from their engineering school so
I ended up going to do entrepreneurial
management and bioengineering as my
bachelor's and mechanical engineering
for my masters so I just want to share a
little bit of house we was able to
affect my college experience it was
amazing I think the thing that really
impresses me most about ski is that it
really touches on three different
aspects so you have the outreach part of
it so getting to speak with you guys I'm
getting to engage with K through 12
students and really get them excited
about stem and Sheldon what's possible
second part is with the professional
development so being able to look at
resumes do mock interviews just grow
yourself personally and professionally I
think is so important no matter
the old you end up going into and then
they're just the fun social aspects so
the fact that you guys are getting to
have lunch here right now I'm getting to
engage with people at different socials
and things like that is just really fun
so I have in upper left hand corner to
picture of the sweet Boston group here
so everyone in the Boston area can be
part of that I was on the board
directors actually for sweet during my
senior year I'm super senior year when i
was doing my masters which is really
cool so getting to interact with people
from all around the world and really
move the strategy is sweet forward and
on just a couple fun pictures one from
my collegiate section at penn their
engineering chick t-shirts and then a
fun photo booth that one over annual
conferences so ladies you want to tell a
little bit about yourself yeah so how
many of you people like uh master
classes quite a few what about science
classes quite just about everybody right
how many of you like English Allah be
all right without writing so I will tell
you right now that when I started in
high school I actually hated my science
classes and so I'm here to tell you
about my journey from being an English
major to becoming an engineer and so
when I was in high school I actually
hated science class because all we did
was fill and [ __ ] fill in the blank
worksheets we didn't do anything like
you know take apart hands like you guys
are doing today and so I was really
bored with science even though I was
really good at it so when I applied to
college I went to rice university I
decided from an English major and at the
end of the my freshman year I applied
for an internship in writing at the
Texas Heart Institute and so basically
what they did there was they took all
the writing that any of the surgeons did
on all the surgeries that they do all
the science research they they do and
they try it they send it to us that way
we can
actually put it into a form that
everybody else can work and so while I
was sitting there and like you know they
want to meet because they wanted me to
track the English or like you know make
sure that i use flowed well but while I
was reading all these things I had no
idea what they were saying I didn't know
what was going on you know there's a lot
of disconnect that people say that
scientists don't know how to explain
things to everybody else and so that was
the problem that I was seeing and I
didn't know what was going on so I asked
my boss can I go see a surgery I don't
know what they're talking about and
while I was in that surgery room the
surgery I saw was on a cow that had had
a mechanical Bell implanted into the
heart and this valve had failed now I
mean you know that's really
disappointing right but there are a lot
of things that we can learn from failure
and so everything that they were doing
when as they were taking out the
mountain running tests through the cow
and figuring out what went wrong I
started to see wow you know there are
these real applications of science that
can be fascinating and so as I was
working my way through the summer I
thought more and more about these
experiences and these things and i was
seeing in the science room the research
realm i was like ok you know maybe I can
go back to school and check out a
bioengineering class and I have to tell
you that I loved it so when I went to
graduate school because i had seen all
these failures which is mechanical
valves and with all these heart devices
I thought maybe tissue engineering would
be a bad or white dome doing it took me
by here know what tissue engineering is
we'd like cells
Oh so for four people who are not aware
tissue engineering tissue engineering is
figuring out how do we can use cells
from the body and figure out how we can
implant them and put them into repair
for our tissues that way we can not use
mechanical devices and the problem that
is that a lot of things that it's very
hard to get ourselves to do what we want
them to do right we don't know enough
about them I'll may suppose so that when
I came a graduate student and biomedical
engineering I decided I want to work
with stem cells they can turn into any
different potential cell type right so
that the thing that was fascinating is I
knew a lot about stem cells and I was
trying to tell all these people but it
was really difficult to tip for people
to understand that and so as I was going
through my journey and trying to tell
people this is interesting this is
fascinating this is why you should learn
it I realize more and more people need
to understand that they need to have an
English background and need to have a
writing background as well and so my
love and English in English and bright
and came back and now that you are
merged and so right now I'm applying for
a lot of positions in journal editing as
an editor for life nature or like
science I'm sure you've heard some these
journals and basically what i'm going to
do is going to be combining my love of
science and engineering and talk turning
into writing that everybody else can
understand is that way we can get even
more people excited
I just want to share a few different
opportunities that you can look into no
matter what grade you're in and I think
it's really cool to just kind of keep
these on the back of your mind because
you never know what might get you really
excited about something and so one
program that's really neat and is run by
the society as a whole is to me next so
this is for girls who are at the age of
18 I believe and so what you can do is
there's tons of different activities
that are through the program you can
learn about scholarships that are
available to you they do quarterly
webinars so that you can kind of
interact with the rest of the community
around you and just get to see other
girls who are really excited about it so
definitely look into that it's a really
great thing that we launched I there
last year a couple years ago and its
really been exploding the other thing
that I would say since I assume most of
your based in the Boston area look into
some of the events that are hosted by
three sections so us from sweet Boston
we host things as a professional section
and this is a taste of some of the
activities that we did this year and so
you can see we partner with the Girl
Scouts who partner with a lot of
organizations partner Kristin for the
girls who filled and we also get to
interact with a lot of the community
event so the Cambridge Science Festival
for instance which happened a couple
months ago um the other thing I would
say is also look into some of the
collegiates we event I know MIT has a
huge presence with their sweet section
and they do a lot of outreach
opportunities for high school girls and
a lot of the other sections in the area
do that as well and I think just like
the biggest takeaway is that you never
know what might excite you I certainly
did not imagine that I would be working
at Microsoft now with my background
being bio engineering mechanical
engineering but as long as you're
passionate about something and as Lane
said you could go from English into
science as well there's just really so
much potential for you so if you want to
get in touch with us and I put my a
contact here and then the sweet Boston
suction contacts as well um so if you
have any questions about some of the
outreach event things and that we do
feel free to get in touch with us well
thank you very much
you